[Applause]
for example I was watching Judge Judy
the other day okay and I know Judge Judy
I know that show when I was checking out
Judge Judy and then I just thought I'll
hit the info button so I hit it and said
this is your last chance to watch before
she's appointed to the Supreme Court
okay which actually I'd be happy yeah I
might not be bad I was watching Dance
Moms I was watching the show Dance Moms
yeah and I thought I'll just check the
info button so I hit it and it said a
documentary about mothers enjoying their
precious last three weeks of custody
yeah yeah and I'm watching NCIS that
show NCIS mm-hmm I was watching a bit
and then I decided I'll hit the info
button it says if you're the typical
viewer stay tuned right afterwards for
the bright white light by the way this
number these are relentlessly grim all
right yes West world that's watching the
show West world loved that show watching
West world yeah and then I hit the
button and it said televisions number
one source for robot Wang that's not
grim at all
no no that's upbeat that's Optima that's
this country needs more robot Wang let's
check out the Golf Channel Golf Channel
of all things here's the Golf Channel
and then I hit the button it said the
closest thing on TV to still photo
[Music]
look at that for a long time yeah here
we go
I was watching Madame secretary Madam
Secretary good show and I hit the button
and said if you want to see a female in
a prominent position in the US
government enjoy this fictional TV show
Texas flippin move is a show yeah Texas
flipping it's on the DIY Network I
didn't know much about it so I hit the
button it said don't know much about the
show other than there's probably a guy
he named Randy in it seems like a safe
bet he got some very safe yeah yeah yeah
burnt notice you ever heard that show
and II notice yeah Burn Notice Burn
Notice yeah Burn Notice and then I hit
the button it said tonight the very last
person is burned and given notice well
yeah boiler he's watching the show big
brother for a while and I hit the button
and it said dum-dums stay indoors and
finally Celebrity Apprentice was on
Celebrity Apprentice I was checking it
out and then I hit the button it said
don't waste your time becoming a Yale
Law School graduate u.s. senator and
Secretary of State when you can become
president by making porn stars throw a
bake sale
[Applause]
you